jeudi dernier ce qui devait être un vol
à l'arraché a finalement viré au drame
ce jeune qui a essayé de voler un sac a
été coupé en deux par un train alors
qu'il était sur le quai d'une gare un
homme est pris à parti par deux
individus qui tentent de lui dérober son
sac mais l'usager se défend une
altercation éclate l'un des agresseurs
se retrouve alors projeté sur les rails
et percutés par un train un drame qui a
valu à la victime du vol d’être placé en
garde à vue le magistrat va vouloir voir
s'il y a eu l'intention par exemple de
la victime de pousser délibérément
l'agresseur sur les rails une garde à
vue qui avait indignée de nombreux
Français à lui voler son sac qui ne sont
rien arrivés à personne mais tandis que
son dossier est toujours à l'étude
l'homme vient finalement de ressortir
libre alors un homme meurt après avoir
tenté de voler un passant que s'est-il
vraiment passé
merci Jean-Christophe couvi secrétaire
général SGP Police merci d'être là
est-ce que vous pouvez nous raconter
raconter à nos téléspectateurs
chroniqueurs au public ce qui s'est
passé jeudi soir à la gare de
Maisons-Alfort un jeudi soir en fait une
personne qui était au téléphone sur un
sur un quai de gare effectivement
attends le train et puis deux individus
arrivent lui s'utilise son sac il s'en
rend compte et du coup bah il veut
récupérer ses biens effectivement une
bagarre déclenche et dans la bagarre il
y a un des deux médiérants qui est tombé
sur les rails malheureusement
effectivement un train est passé et il
n'a pas pu n'a pas pu freiner alors
la victime de la tentative de vol
l'autre
enfin l'autre agresseur il est lui il a
été il a été interpellé interpellé
effectivement par par mes collègues il y
avait la cynophile du du département 75
plus des effectifs de cette
Maison-Alfort qui sont arrivés et
effectivement qui l'ont qui l'ont
interpellé à interpellé et qui ont aussi
effectivement recueillis les premiers
témoignages il y avait trois témoins
heureusement d'ailleurs puisque dans
l'enquête
on s'aperçoit vite que il y a une vidéo
surveillance qui était mal orientée et
qui ne marchait pas forcément donc
forcément heureusement qu'il y avait les
témoins qui ont pu témoigner et qui ont
pu expliquer la scène et c'est ça qui
est très important en fait dans une
enquête de police et d'avoir le recueil
le recueil de tous les témoignages en
fait pour donner bien sûr alors
aujourd'hui la victime de la tentative
de vol
était en garde à vue donc là monsieur
qui s'est défendu aujourd'hui est sorti
de garde à vue oui c'est les sorties
samedi soir à 20h donc maintenant en
fait si vous voulez l'enquête a été
menée on a recueilli effectivement ces
propos on a recueilli les propos des
témoins et on appelle ça un avis au
magistrat donc au procure la République
qui a l'opportunité des la poursuite
donc au vu de ce que l'enquête va va
démontrer et ce qu'on a donné comme
comme preuve au magistrat effectivement
maintenant la magistrature va décider si
une suite à donner ou pas alors il
pourrait être poursuivi dans le sens où
par exemple il s'avérait et là il faut
il faut voir l'effet moi j'ai pas accès
au dossier mais si par exemple
délibérément il avait projeté sur les
rails dans l'intention de le tuer par
exemple voilà là en l'occurrence c'est
une bagarre d'après les premiers
éléments c'est vraiment un accident un
incident sur un coup de poing l'autre
personne est déséquilibré elle tombe et
lui il s'occupe justement de sauver
parce qu'il y a un échange de cours en
fait d'accord voilà alors c'est vrai que
Gilles c'est l'affaire incroyable et la
faire incroyable et je vais peut-être
vous surprendre mais moi je suis
totalement du côté de la victime qui
pour moi est la personne qui a été
attaquée je vais vous expliquer pourquoi
je connais bien cet endroit et c'est
vrai qu'il y a des TGV qui passent très
vite et cette personne a fait ce que
personne ne fait jamais c'est-à-dire
qu'on lui a dérobé ses objets et il a
poursuivi les deux agresseurs et selon
mes infos mais je vous allez peut-être
pouvoir me le confirmer l'un des deux
aurait sorti un couteau à ce moment-là
devant lui là c'est encore un certain
donc le monsieur se rebelle et il ne se
laisse pas faire et c'est vrai qu'à ce
moment-là un des deux tombe et moi je
suis tout à fait content que pour le
moment il soit ressorti libre de sa
garde à vue j'espère que ce ne sera pas
judiciarisé en revanche l'un des deux
mineurs isolés celui qui est donc en
vice sera jugé le 23 mai pour tentative
de vol aggravé il y a beaucoup de
circonstances à gravantes et il pourrait
être condamné à de la prison et moi j'en
ai marre je prends les transports en
permanence j'en ai marre de ces
agressions dans les transports c'est
insupportable donc je comprends
parfaitement que cet homme est là s'il y
a un mort c'est dramatique mais je
comprends que cet homme se soit rebellé
on peut pas se faire dérober en
permanence ses effets dans les
transports ce n'est plus possible voilà
oui Valérie tu étais contre la vidéo
surveillance et là en l'occurrence elle
faisait défaut elle m'a servi
heureusement qu'elle a heureusement
qu'il y avait comme ady monsieur des
témoins qui ont permis de corroborer la
version de la victime parce que sinon
s'il n'y avait pas eu de la vidéo
surveillance parce qu'elle était mal
orientée qu'elle ne permettait pas de
voir la scène ben on n'aurait pas su et
peut-être que ce monsieur aurait été
embêté par la justice
la vidéo surveillance
c'est les témoins c'est les témoins et
les policiers de Maisons-Alfort ont agi
très rapidement voilà et donc orientées
donc aujourd'hui c'est vrai que parce
que il y a plein de gens on dit qu'on
était un peu choqués que cette personne
soit mise en garde à vue mais c'est la
procédure à un moment il faut bien qu'on
sache
on est d'accord en fait il faut
comprendre avant de pouvoir condamner et
l'enquête sert à ça elle sert à mettre
de la vérité sur ce qui s'est passé
c'est à mettre de la lumière sur sur ça
et justement ce qui est ce qui est
important c'est en fait c'est dans une
fraction de seconde votre vie échange
c'est à dire que vous êtes victime vous
demandez rien à personne vous êtes sur
un quai de gare vous téléphonez à votre
copine ou à votre famille et d'un seul
coup il y a des personnes qui se
rencontrent qui viennent d'un univers
complètement différent et votre vie
bascule parce que même cette personne
qui est victime toute sa vie va s'en
rappeler parce que incidament il a quand
même été là et là une personne est
décédée quand même et lui aussi il va
devoir vivre avec ça toute sa vie donc
encore une fois il y en a qui vont
peut-être nous parler de karma ou de loi
de causes à effet mais n'empêche que si
on vit dans le bien on ne meurt pas
comme ça bêtement j'allais dire écrasé
par un TGV mais c'est sûr
pourquoi la garde à vue pouvait être
reçue par la police et son régime de
garde à vue qui est un peu violent quand
même en étant victime alors en fait une
garde à vue c'est c'est très bien traité
par la police parce que justement on
sait aussi faire la part des choses et
il y a des gardes à vue en cellule et
des garde à vue qu'on appelle un peu
aménagé on voit bien qu'il y a une
personne voilà qui qui n'a rien demandé
à personne et donc on sent le met dans
une pièce avec nous on discute vous
savez dans les commissariats dans les y
compris même avec des gens qui ont
commis le pire ils se passent un huis
clos entre les policiers les enquêteurs
et les personnes qui sont mis en garde à
vue et il y a beaucoup d'humanité
contrairement à ce qu'on peut penser il
y a beaucoup d'échanges il y a beaucoup
de psychologie il y a même voilà des des
collègues des fois qui me disent et bien
on en discute qui offre des frites qui
qui vont chercher un McDo parce que
justement c'est des fois on a on a cette
tendance
[Musique]
effectivement c'est avoir du
discernement c'est savoir comment mais
après je pense un réflexe il y a des
gens en fait voilà il y a plusieurs
réflexes en fait si vous voulez quand
vous êtes en situation de stress c'est
soit vous faites front ce qui a fait ce
cette personne soit vous fuyez soit vous
restez tétanisé mais ça c'est pas vous
qui commandez si vous voulez c'est votre
cerveau qui commande juste
Jean-Christophe moi pour revenir un
petit peu sur ce que vous avez dit tout
à l'heure pour téléspectateurs ils vont
te dire il y a un truc ça veut dire que
en fait
on se fait agresser par exemple et on
doit donc un petit peu contrôlé en fait
sa riposte parce que si on fait une trop
grosse on risque de se retrouver voilà
c'est quand même fou ça parce que c'est
un moment demande
tu peux te retrouver
ton sac à un moment tu as personne est
armée si elle a un couteau
à un moment à un moment tu fais le
maximum pour le mettre au cas où en de
nuire je suis désolé les mecs
en fait on sait pas comment réagit parce
que là là vous pouvez dire
moi si quelqu'un me fait ça je vais me
révolter et je vais mettre la tête au
carré sauf que dans l'instant avec le la
surprise la peur parce qu'on a un afflux
d'adrénaline etc vous savez pas comment
vous allez réagir ah mais justement si
on réagit trop comment ça se passe ah
mais trop ben après c'est
du discernement c'est il faut faire
cesser l'infraction après ça en fait si
vous voulez c'est
la légitime défense et ça c'est je me
défends mais je ne me venge pas c'est
encore une fois que l'infraction est
laissée par exemple vous avez récupéré
WhatsApp et que tu vois on va pas lui
sauter dessus on va pas le voilà
l'important c'est c'est le de
l'interpeller si on peut effectivement
pour pour voilà pour l'interpeller après
le présenter un officier de police
judiciaire ça c'est c'est dans le code
pénal mais surtout c'est vous mettre en
sécurité toujours voilà oui j'espère
qu'il y aura aucune charge retenu contre
lui parce que d'abord il y a pas de
préméditation forcément c'est lui quand
même la victime qui a été agressée et
quand il a jeté ce mineur sur la voie le
TGV est passé à ce moment-là je pense
pas qu'il avait l'horreur de train du
TGV qui est passé à ce moment-là quoi
donc bien sûr franchement on peut pas
retenir de charge quand on se met
monsieur j'espère qu'il aura rien mais
j'espère moi aussi que au vu du dossier
et le magistrat pour effectivement
classer cette affaire oui c'est sûr que
les policiers sont de votre avis
c'est-à-dire pour les policiers il y a
pas lieu de judiciarisé mais le
procureur peut dire quand même qu'il y
avait une intention éventuelle de
pousser et à ce moment-là si c'était ça
homicide involontaire la victime
risquerait gros c'est pour ça que c'est
une première étape importante mais c'est
pas gagné encore au niveau de la justice
pour cette personne là